la crisis política tiene repercusiones
en la economía de los argentinos los
roces dentro de la coalición que
gobierna el país ponen más presión sobre
unos precios ya muy elevados amaneció
que todo el mundo puso carteles 20 por
ciento más del precio actual la crisis
escaló el pasado fin de semana con la
renuncia del ministro de economía martín
guzmán negociador en el recién aprobado
acuerdo de refinanciación de deuda con
el fmi y la salida del ministro disparó
el cambio del dólar en el mercado
informal lo que repercute en los precios
de los establecimientos que promediaron
en un 20 por ciento sus incrementos una
estrategia con la que buscan defenderse
ante la devaluación de la moneda local
un factor endémico en la nación
suramericana lo que no deja de preocupar
a muchos pero que frenen pero que frenen
porque la verdad es que es una locura no
sabes cómo manejar los precios no sabes
con cuanta plata van a hacer al mercado
cuanta marca día puedes comprar antes
ahora puedes vender
porque le hará un montón a la mente no
va a poder comprar el gobierno de
alberto fernández trabaja además por
saldar una deuda de unos 40 mil millones
de dólares con el fondo monetario
internacional adquirida por mauricio
macri por detrás de venezuela argentina
es el país con más inflación de las
naciones suramericanas con un 60,7 por
ciento anual sin embargo los mismos
comerciantes se reconocen que a pesar
del incremento de los precios las ventas
no se detienen en otras palabras para
los argentinos comprar es ahorrar ante
el temor de que los precios sigan
aumentando tan bruscamente de la noche a
la mañana